coming up next week in Brussels organic
farming border management and a mini
plenary brings the president of Israel
and the Palestinian National Authority
to Brussels
welcome to the agenda in the Europe
expanding the scope of counterterrorism
measures at the expense of fundamental
rights with multiple devastating attacks
across France and Belgium and with a
lone-wolf attacks on the rise the threat
posed by the Islamic state is massive
the civil liberties committee are set to
vote on Tuesday on a draft directive
that looks to outlaw the travel of
foreign fighters give support to victims
of terrorism and try to counter online
propaganda by terrorist groups and
sympathizers in the name of security
could the free movement of EU citizens
be curtailed no even if some borders
were closed for a short time after
terrorist attacks but concerns remain
over the alarming number of EU foreign
fighters traveling to Iraq and Syria and
the threat they then pose on their
return to Europe after radicalization to
crack down the EU wants to introduce
systemic checks of all EU and non-eu
citizens when they're traveling across
external borders of the Union and also
to put checks on third country nationals
when they are leaving the EU the
controversial proposal is put to a vote
on Tuesday at the civil liberties
committee a mini plenary this week
brings the president of the Palestinian
National Authority and Israel to the
parliament trouble is brewing between
the two neighbors once again after
Israel's National Water Company cut off
water supply to large parts of West Bank
during the holy month of Ramadan leaving
thousands without clean drinking water
the tensions high as ever both
presidential addresses will be food for
fodder the Israeli president addresses
any peas on Wednesday at 3:00 p.m. and
on Thursday Mahmoud Abbas takes a stage
at 11:00 a.m. and now for a quick look
at what else is on at the mini plenary
what property rights do international
couples have especially if there's a
dispute which EU country laws can apply
watch out for joint debate on Wednesday
the EU foreign affairs chief federica
mogherini will make a statement on the
ongoing killings in eastern DRC on
Wednesday on Thursday morning there'll
be a joint debate between the EU
Commission and Parliament on the state
of play of energy reform visa fees
renewable energy and efficiency and also
look out for Europe on TV interview with
the authors of
final report by the Special Committee on
tax ruling tax two MVPs vote on the
draft report on Tuesday any regulation
on farming could come into force by the
middle of next year but could it place
unnecessary burdens on organic farmers
no longer a niche market organic
products generate twenty billion euros
every year under plans organic and
non-organic farming will not be allowed
on the same land and all products
labeled as organic will be subject to
stricter test to ensure overall better
quality on Tuesday any piece of
Agriculture Committee will discuss a
state of play of final negotiations on
legislative changes taking place between
representatives of the Parliament and
member states and that's all we have
this agenda to take care and enjoy the
week